yeah hello and welcome to new video um
yeah this time it's a yes something else
so to say um yeah actually I just
intended to to do a really quick video
of I now just three to five minutes or
something um and attending to show some
some game fragment that that that I
actually played and this is might sound
funny that I actually played them
against my mobile phone on a train right
yeah sometimes like to kill time to just
play a quick game some was my iphone and
sorry um and I just said it it's it's
it's a shredder engine but I just said
it on a rather weak level so to just
have some quick games and have some fun
and yes somehow in this game it it
turned out that i had very nice
attacking idea and the nice attacking
combination and the fun thing about this
was that on when i when i played this
and thought about on making a small
video of this i somehow got the the
nagging feeling that I saw this kind of
this kind of attacking idea before and i
did a search in my my chest based some
mega database trying to find exactly the
same attacking procedure and um well I
didn't find exactly the same may be
added to the search wrong or something
but I didn't find exactly the same but I
found a very similar attacking concept
you know in the real tournament game
played a couple of years ago and this is
the second game fragment I'd like to
show because it's just a fantastic game
and I didn't know this game of course
and it's I guess one of those unknown
brilliant sees that somehow
yeah nobody knows about because actually
yeah the the wrong player one in this
game okay but this is the second part of
the video okay let's start out um with
this fun game against my mobile phone
and we got this position after black so
nineteenth move on it just played the
bishop to f6 and cold okay this is some
a decent idea to cover the g7 square we
can see I'm in this position White has
already put some pieces on really active
at taking squares for instance the rook
whoops I didn't intend to do that for
instance the rook has got the idea on g7
somehow I keep hitting the room the
wrong button here g7 of course and also
the bishops lining up towards g7 and the
other work on d3 is also ready to jump
in so white has some some nice attacking
potential so Bishop we have six just
locked this diagonal and I didn't yeah I
didn't see an instant way to to get
forward so I played King h1 yeah this
game wasn't like me thinking five
minutes for move just playing some quick
moves to to kill time so King aged 12 to
get the F porn going maybe and get some
more attacking force in and now the
phone now played the bishop H form
somewhat strange move but ok it's a it's
not a not a mega our chess computers
just a phone hey rook to f3 and wanted
to cover f2 and then it played all night
to f6 and here I a post from minute or
so and had some interesting idea how to
get something here against the black
king so if you are from from Iran it's
actually a forcing win for white
it's a completely straightforward I
didn't see it all when i when i when i
played it when i saw the the basic ideas
and checked it afterwards with my real
computer here and it's actually working
so if you want to do or to check for
yourself what's coming up now so you
might pause the video and take yourself
some time it's not that easy to work out
if you got some experience in this kind
of attacking formations with bishop in
on b2 and rooks on third-ranked you
might find it quicker but we just stop
the video and take yourself some time
and think about what white might try em
okay I'll continue the video now so make
sure to hit to hit the pause button if
you want to look for yourself so I
played the first of all a pledge III
here which forces some of g5 an H form
completely forced the bishop is detect
and it just got nothing else and VG to
h6 and now the fun starts I think the
first move is actually yeah the first
move you should consider in such a
position because you need to look at the
defending pieces and well this is just
the first move to think of but it's the
difficult part is to put it all together
so wyd a sacrifice is the exchange here
to get rid of the night and gtech sub 6
and now the next hit if you see in the
first one you might as well on since the
second one 95 it's a very very powerful
move which opens the long diagonal for
the bishop now it's got the whole way
open
to the king so what kind of position
what kind of possibilities are here
actually the program mode took the night
but let's just look quickly at other
possibilities um leg also could have fun
tuck the king in the corner here then
strong possibility is just to capture
with the night threatening all kinds of
discoveries like NAT D seven for
instance winning the Queen so black
needs to to block the diagonal Bishop g7
and now White has a powerful blow again
very nice-looking move rug d5 the whole
idea of this piece sacrifice on d5 the
same with the night sacrifices to to
block the fifth-ranked and to join in
with the Queen on h5 for instance so if
black would take now let's say he takes
a look then white could simply pay
GreenEDGE five threatening made on age
seven black if black takes it's the
simple made configuration so black needs
to play age six and then why'd it's got
simple move Queen f5 just threatening on
age 7 and as black has no checks or
anything to disturb white hits to take
here and then it just made next move
yeah what else could black do on 95 he
could try to block the diagonal of
course okay here white would have some
simple arm moves as well to get a great
position but the strongest is not chief
Queen to g4 check
Jade Queen to f5 now threatening to take
with the knight on f6 and then have the
meydan h7 we should g7 to cover our six
and then the very strong move Bishop see
one with the idea or any move basically
yeah well almost any move let's say
Quincy six just to make a move then why
it has to blow Bishop h6 if black takes
now then it's all over again after night
xf6 so white has a crushing attack here
so taking the night it's no mistake it's
a very bad position anyway now the check
on g4 of course simple is this one just
the maid on g7 nothing black and do so
Bishop g5 is the only move and here I
actually miss them a better better
continuation I played subjects f6 is
also a winning move but far nice that
would have been here too to take with
the rook on d5 let's say Quint x f2 and
then the very nice finishing touch Queen
takes g5 for instance takes has just
made in one very nice just with the
bishop and the rook and of course if he
steps aside white also wins was Bishop
f6 or queen 06 for instance this one may
be the nicest one always nice to have
these some mating patterns so what you
need to remember of this long diagonal
bishop it's it's very often close to
mate night on e seven is made net on h6
is made and a check on the g4 is also
made with a rook or the Queen
so this is also what led me to discover
this because i saw that i can open up
the long diagonal and get a queen to g4
and this is the mating pattern so Bishop
g5 had played and now I didn't play
rugby five which is quicker when I
played Bishop takes on f6 and now at
some it's still not possible to do
anything really Queen takes g5 a
threatened with maiden one so he needs
to cover g5 some somewhere somewhere um
and now i just i just took with the pawn
I didn't see anything that black can do
against the simple Queen to the H file
Queen h6 Queen g7 made and basically
there is nothing it's just not as quick
as Luke t5 like now play the Queen
before and there was a bit worried if I
am if I go to h6 that there might be
Queenie one check we need for so I
stepped aside with the King for us that
cannot do anything anyway so b5 mmm it
takes be I just mentioned that here
there's also another nice win um with g6
interesting idea somehow nothing i am i
considered on the idea this is after
taking here it's just just the mate
pretty simple and after F takes g oops i
have this check here and black only has
got Luke f7 and then the rook drops also
nice nice and taking motif to remember
okay but ok this is winning so Queen age
60 it's not able to do anything against
it so just the desperado move and then
made on g7 yeah it's a fun little
combination but okay this is just meant
as an appetizer so to say for for the
main show because
the amazing thing is that this rather
yeah there's an important game against
against my phone prompted me to search
and the database for for this kind of
kind of attacking combination or mixture
of sacrifices and I didn't find exactly
the same but something that is really
really close and it's a tremendous game
it's really really a shame that the
white play of them went astray at some
point I'll show it to you now just a
second I need to to switch the the games
I hope it it's working properly I think
it's ok yeah it's ok yeah this is the
position after the 14th move black like
just played twin to be six I need to
mention the players of course and this
is a tournament game so with the
long-term control from 1994 an open in
an open tournament in France at the
players on the German international
master Matthias water actually I know
quite worrisome teammate of mine in my
badge Belgium team and I would ask him
about this game when I went to see him
next time and on the black player has
some Vladimir hot Nick I guess a Russian
international master both players rated
about 2400 to something at the time okay
take a look at this position and you
notice that there are some similarities
for white you have the rook on the
third-ranked similar to to my my phone
game with possibilities to swing across
the third-ranked you got the strong
Bishop lining up and black similar to to
my game only has got the the bishop and
the night SS defenders there's no bishop
on g6 or something and now after Queen B
6 white really
played an amazing amazing concept it
sacrifice the screen on f6 okay after I
think settling from the shop black took
it then rook g3 check and now black
really has to play Bishop g7 he doesn't
have anything else for instance if he
goes King educate White has 95 this is
no surprise anymore after the first game
so that's the strong thread should takes
f6 with a coming checkmate so Bishop g7
Black has got no time to to to save the
queen just to show it quickly if he m if
he takes the bishop what will take here
and Bishop g7 and actually rook takes g7
is some as completely winning let's say
like tries to to make some space for the
king with the h porn then white even has
got the time to to play this year and to
bring the bishop over with with with
Bishop d3 and then the mage pattern
would be grouped 2h7 Andrew graduate
mate let's make a quick example here if
black plays anything let's say rupee aid
then we've got something like this and
those bishop and the rook just win the
win the game for white with the mate k
black and put various pieces in the way
but it's just a devastating attack so
after a night to d5
black needs to play Bishop g7 and then
White has so nice choice you can just
recapture the Queen on b6 for some
really weird form of Queen trade but you
will of course end up with a really
superior position because of the pawn
structure he actually has got even more
powerful movie again you can take on g7
even if you look at this position you'll
see then that this is just identical to
the one I've shown before with a winning
attack for white it takes with the king
y can just take here King move somewhere
and then you will capture the Queen and
now both rooks are hanging so what will
you gain an exchange and end up with
them yeah almost winning technical end
game with an extra porn compared to some
stuff happening in the game this might
be some of legs best option but okay
this is not a practical choice because
blue is impossible to calculate what
happens in the game I think okay play
dumb Bishop to juice heavens just a
normal move to play and now I dumb
struck the next blow with them Knight to
g5 yeah the similarity assign are we
striking between those two games of
course this is a different kind of ball
games far more difficult the variations
to to consider um actually I was also
looking here at another move I don't
want to to show everything here because
it's it would take a really long time
I'll post the game of course in the
description so we've got the chance to
to look at it yourself another
interesting move here besides 95 which
is the strongest one you played the
strongest move but another
interesting possibility is the somewhat
counterintuitive maybe 94 it's look so
much strange to put the night on the on
the edge of the board of course after
you just sacrifice the Queen for just
one minor piece but still it's it's
interesting to consider I think it's
also close to winning for white but 95
which is stronger edges so one point am
of course like wants to save the queen
white takes on f6 and you will get the
second piece for for the Queen and will
continue to have a really strong attack
but this is not completely forced maybe
so um it would take some really deep
analysis to prove a white is winning
here or if it is just let's say a clear
advantage night air force also really a
really good move um which might win the
game but it's not it's not easy if you
get got some time on your hand um try to
go through these lines as well maybe
also with the help of a computer to
check what you're thinking yourself
because it's it's terribly complicated
um but okay he played 95 and this is its
strongest move and it's also winning but
not easy okay black took it what else
could he do and Bishop f6 note that
white now is the complete whole Queen
down but of course it is a strong attack
and whites main idea of course I'm a
mating nets so blacks best move here and
he played the best move is king of eight
anticipating now the capture on g7 white
not took with rook and now we see the
kind of made widest after he wants to
play just look to rook takes h7 or group
2h7 and rook
meat and the somewhat congested
formation of black's pieces with the
bishop on d7 rukan d8 makes it really
difficult for him to get out of this
somewhere he also doesn't have from grid
squares for his pieces for instance the
bishop on g7 it doesn't have fun really
um he doesn't it doesn't have a great
place to go and it also just blocks them
this sum square on d7 so legs best
defense now is some um Bishop to e6
which he played also if you just have a
quick look what happens if like this
nothing moved let's say he moves to
rockaway then this is already checkmate
because this heaven is just is just the
the final nail in the coffin that takes
away the d7 square check made on a jade
so black needs to move oops in this
position the bishop and it doesn't have
any thing else and go to e6 note that um
let's say I'm Bishop c6 wouldn't help
because then this Bishop comes in and
takes the d7 square with really a great
great picture here with the two bishops
and the rook doing the job the c1 rook
is just a spectator here and white it's
doing this meeting attack just with the
bishop and the strong look on the 7th so
blood needs to play we should be six
there's no other move and at this point
on white I think um made things a little
bit more difficult than they're
necessary um he could have one here with
rook tank at age seven he played 65 but
still
conserves a large advantage maybe maybe
even a winning one but Luke takes h7 was
was stronger let's have a look rook
takes h7 King to e8 it's the only move
and now just see takes d5 yeah this
position where white has really just a
minor piece he's just got this Bishop on
f6 and of course the strong activity and
everything but from a material point of
view is got just one bishop on f6 and
okay now it's two or three pawns but
this is a completely completely winning
position as wide simply threatens to
take only six and then crashes through
on the best defense now this loop dc-8
trying to get a counter-attack on the on
the background here the rukon c1 is
hanging but just just let's just have a
quick look or take it what happens if
black tries to get out with a king maybe
then why just takes here King takes and
then the really murderous rook h6 simply
simply killing move white threatening to
give discovers check with the bishop
also capturing d aid of course so
there's a threat bishop d 4 + d 8 so to
say on the Queen so black cannot save
both the rook the Queen and everything
else so he lose a huge amount of
material here what already has got two
bishops now for the Queen and he will
win at least her room now so it's
completely winning so let's check rocker
dc-8 and now and I think this was maybe
the the problem here for the white
player what he what he missed that here
white needs to just
mega rig move of course Roxy one just
needs to move and he needs to just do a
small sidestep and this this is decisive
maybe he was distracted by some some
strange possibilities the the strongest
relatively strongest move for black now
is Bishop 2 h 3 i'm not sure if if he so
goes there on what what he wanted him
but what he missed him in this
variations the key point here is that
wide also has got this this attacking
idea and this is this is really winning
but i can start a counter-attack on f2
white can just cover this and now for
instance kingly seven let's know nothing
better and white wins just wins rook
here with an ongoing attack still Bishop
e8 threatened made into moose Bishop
eight King c7 Bishop d8 mate an tastic
picture so like you only has got this
one just just to show them a def black
male who makes a nothing move here what
mates like this it's just just beautiful
so um black needs to drop back the rook
and now white can simply exchange here
and I take the bishop it's got rooked
two bishops and for extra points
completely winning and maybe it's a it's
still a strong attack enter from a
material point of view it's actually
winning maybe it would even be winning
without the rook or something just the
bishops and the pawns and just just
completely over so maybe maybe he didn't
really appreciate that
and you just needed to do to make a root
move here in fact the strongest move
here up t 1 is just the human move the
strongest one is is rook f1 shown by the
computer and this is even more killing
than the other other line because it
sort of anticipates blacks counter play
with Roxy to and covers f2 it's well
it's somewhat it's the computer move
it's not human to to see this I guess so
with the point if black now tries to do
to make the counter tech then this is
already already a false checkmate look
h8 of thread here like doesn't have any
King moves so besides some desperado
sacrifices on f2 or something he has to
check this year and this is checkmate
very nice the rooks are the rook and the
bishop doing a great job here so black
cannot do something active and he's
reduced to arm well moves like let's say
our oops let's say rook c5 and then why
just just takes here and continues to
attack with Bishop e6 rook h8 the thread
observe it's just deadly the rook was on
the 5th ranked two to block the check
here so what child like do white is just
threatening root of course we should be
six also a five it's it's just terrible
so black needs to do some some silly
blocking move here after which white can
just take and and win the look with
just huge amount of extra material but
unfortunately in the game just to remind
you this is the game position why should
have taken on on a chair on age seven
but unfortunately it took on it took
with the pointy m and the difference is
the fun thing it is still very good for
white but it's it's just much more
difficult the difference is now black
has got this temple here and there
simply the pair of moves rook h7 at King
eight are not inserted here it's just
it's the same position but white we
fight would he have the chance here
which he doesn't have it because Roxy
one is friend to insert rook h7 King yet
we've got a transposition but now the
Roxy one is hanging and and here white
mr. the best move he played Roxy form
and leave it or not this is still um
probably okay for white this is a queen
down it's still okay but the strongest
movie would have been again Rock d1 and
this can easily lead to a transposition
if black now for instance plays our King
e8 we would probably go go to a very
similar position at the one we examined
before in fact like um has only one move
here which doesn't lose instantly let's
just check quickly this Queen yet is the
movement but let's say what what would
happen if black tries to play king yet
for instance then D is six is winning
rook takes h 7 h-7 would also win
transposition to the one we got before
but this is even
rook g8 threatened and here like just
got got steamrolled by the bishop center
and the rock just just great so black
needs to play the somewhat sorry move
like community eight and now its
simplest to to just grab the Queen yeah
and after the sequence of moves one will
pick up d6 the next move and you will
have fun three pawns on for the exchange
and still a brilliant position with
strong bishops just imagine the bishop
let's say six black doesn't have a
decent move anyway Bishop d6 just
imagine the bishop on going to d4 at
some point we are brilliant position
both bishops on d3 and be 54 would
control the possible entry squares of
the C file and white would be yeah very
much still in the driving seat so large
advantage probably winning it's not
great maid or something but so I think
white would have great winning chances
to him he played a rookie form of course
you do know from just looking at the
game how the time the clock situation
was so maybe white already was in time
trouble I guess at its murderous to play
such stuff of the board okay I'm like
now exchange on c4 Bishop c4 and but you
always have to keep in mind white has
just the bishop and two points at the
moment for the Queen I now black played
on Bishop f5 which is the fighting the
fighting move actually
if you would have retreated the bishop
let's say we should see eight then white
has you'd shown us to to make a draw by
perpetual very funny perpetual coming up
Kingi aid then strong move Bishop e2 the
idea is to play rook age 8 and then
Bishop to g4 the switching off diagonals
black needs to play this one so all only
moves and now very funny we should be a
check King v8 and Bishop g5 and now with
Roxy a threatened black legs only move
is king c7 Bishop be a check and we
gotta draw via perpetual on by
repetition of moves would have been well
maybe yeah nice outcome of the game at
least giving why to draw but you played
Bishop f5 so the fighting option white
took this Andrew creators was the idea
to get the rook and took into the game
and maybe try to get some sort of
counter at check on you one or maybe two
in some lines where the bishop has moved
on c4 and now unfortunately um yeah
white um yeah what made the losing move
it's still possible to to get an unclear
position maybe a drawn position it's
it's a possible to analyze I think on he
played g4 now which is understandable to
get some room for the King on but this
has a huge drawback which is so
immediately which we will see
immediately um he had to play g3 here
and let's say rookie one check and this
is logical to to get this book into the
game and then there are many
possibilities to
to end the game and some sort of
Perpetual on or maybe a repetitions
let's say just just a sample line king
e8 the computer actually gives all this
as 000 so probably it sees all the
Perpetual's and and so on AI cannot show
them all here just just to give a sample
I'm black playing tinny 8g a check King
g7 then we'll get fate to h5 rook takes
King yate look aged seven white still
has a strong initiative here with with
the rook under seven and the bishops for
instance something like this would be
one of the Perpetual's i mentioned black
cannot escape p.m. from all this checks
or he will roast more material so G 3
would probably not sure lead to a draw
at least on white would be able to to
fight on and I think it's got huge
chances of getting one of those
repetitions a wide unfortunately play G
form and I think maybe you overlooked
rookie for and this is really really
strong the the problem here is that
white in order to get something going
against the king um really needs to play
um group takes h7 but then g4 falls and
everything else is answered well let's
just have a quick look what happened in
the game wipe late King g2 and then
repair form and resigns as f2 is so it's
just falling yeah set septum and to this
great game
um white head to play rook takes h7 but
then after Ruby form check King everyone
and then some move let's say green a 5
don't want to analyze this too deeply
it's not as interesting as Alliance
before um then black will get huge
counter play against the king so they
are fighting chances of course but most
probably black will win let's say rook
h8 create check here King g7 and then
something like something like this black
will most likely get out of the worst
here because the rook is not on 7th
anymore and he has got some counter
threats on his own against a to maybe
I'll just get the Queen and give a
couple of checks leg is better here what
could fight but like it's better
unfortunately as I am already show
briefly played ping g2 and after you get
for resigned maybe it's it's very likely
that there was a huge time travel
involved which is of course no surprise
considering the yeah the very
complicated nature of the game just want
to UM go quickly to the main points here
yes this is the arrows are still in
there so really white unleashes the
power of the bishop 1 B 2 and the rook
on the third rank with this nice
combination of sacrifices and gets on
the 7th rank with the rook combined with
the bishop on f6 and he could have from
the crown as his great preparatory work
here with rook takes h7 which would have
won I didn't I didn't show all the lines
some I had a look at because I'm already
suspected this video would get rather
long
passed the 40-minute mark no so if you
are interested on just check out the the
PGN for the PGN copied that are now
posted in the description and have a
look at yourself there are really great
great variations in this in this game
also it's maybe not not interesting yeah
from technical point of view because 95
was strong and good the variations after
native words also also interesting it's
our only shot tip of the iceberg there
yeah this was a think a fun video with
the great attacking game and it's very
unfortunate that that white um I wasn't
able to win it actually yeah I think
maybe a lot of games which feature
brilliant concepts by one player but
unfortunately at some point they missed
the right continuation or got into tram
trouble and somehow spoiled and so on
maybe those games I never really
published or simply forgotten after time
and the only i only found found this
great game by by coincidence because I
played I played this yeah with this
silly game against against the the
telefonia and then and found him those
kind of attacking scheming term and dug
it up in the database on as always
beautiful things to discover in chess on
yeah okay thanks for for watching the
video make sure to leave a question the
comments here and also think of from
subscribing to the channel it's um it's
it's free there's no obligation involved
but you get informed when new videos
uploaded yeah thanks for watching and
see you soon